let me start by saying congratulations
thanks um I cannot I'm so I'm fascinated
by the editing process because
ultimately that's where the movie comes
together so when did you actually finish
this movie like yesterday is are you
still working on it yeah that's how it
feels I gotta say we were in can to
yesterday but but the Thursday but it
was I literally finished the Friday
before Saturday and I'm sitting there
watching it Friday thinking have I done
everything like a knows you know I
learnt this really important lesson it's
like you never finish you just run out
of time and it's it's a really
interesting way to sort of live your
life by because it means it was always
something more that you feel you've got
to do but yeah we sort of got it let it
go and now we're on this mad ride I'm
very curious in the editing room and
you're putting this thing together the
thing that the listen you did such a
great job with this material but you
managed to do some really hard stuff by
making these fantasy musical sequences
work with dramatic scenes like it's you
did a great job with all this thinking
when you're in the editing room for you
what was the toughest sequence or the
tone if you will of putting all this
together and making it work the musical
numbers are always tough they are
because with the best will in the world
if they're not telling the story if
they're not moving it forward
particularly in a musical because there
the danger is I suppose is you get so
wrapped up in just the musicality of it
all that it's got to be more that it
still keeps moving it forward and that's
what I'm always keen I don't want them I
never wanted the film to just sit back
okay now we're just listening to some
music and I want to keep the drama alive
I want to keep it keep it going and and
and sometimes I suppose when you watch
it lots and lots of knots and you go
through it is that you it can you can
fall into the trap of doubting that that
that's what's that means you follow I'm
saying completely and and so they're
difficult because they're so important
is so important and I know sometimes
they really work with Jamie Bell sings
goodbye yellow brick road I mean you're
in that moment you understand what he's
saying what he wants to deliver to well
and what he he needs to talk to his
friend about
so they're they're the kind of things
that I worried about it's like is it
still working is it moving
the narrative in the drama forward is
the carrots are still conflicted and
growing and moving forward so yeah and
but also I'm really protective of them
because they're really lovely you know I
want love is for people sitting around a
dining room table but walking around
their own but it's it's gotta hold our
attention and I know it's just
beautifully sung and beautiful music so
that's the end that's always a balance I
think I always asked us the filmmakers
but how long was your first cut compared
to the finished film my first cut was 2
hours and 48 minutes and was that a cut
that you were like I can show this or
that was like worse than all that was
ever that's woopsy no no that's that's
you know we know what you learn is what
I do is you know you add all of these
things and with a film like Rocket Man
it it's endeavours to be as layered and
nuanced as possible and so that's sort
of like ordering everything on the menu
and then going okay I'm gonna take this
and that and that makes the meal okay
that makes it satisfying and like you
but you owned this really good asparagus
I said I know but you know I can't
completely but this leads me to what
might be my last question obviously when
you're you have to get to the to our
running time or you got to get to a cut
that you're happy with in the studio's
happy with mmm what were the last two or
three scenes that you pulled out like
deleted stuff that came so close to
being in and why were they removed
there's a really insane scene backstage
before he comes onstage in Australia
where he's dressed as a Queen Elizabeth
way he's really lost and he's sort of in
this tent from about sushi you know it's
like I can't go on stage I've only got
eating sushi you know it's Aaron is just
sublime in its but in this brilliant and
funny and tragic and and and you know
and I love it and I know Taryn loves
that scene as well and it'll be in the
DVD extras in it but it's just it's just
like when it gets too much it's like we
know where is that and we need to keep
things moving and and and it we just
didn't need it I had to really
do we need another scene where we see
our broken and lost the SB we get it and
the scene that follows also does the
same thing so once things start doubling
up you've got to make that hard decision
which one do I go with do I go with you
know the scene where it breaks down on
stage or backstage where he's being a
bit of a diva you know so we call it the
sushi scene sure and you know I know
Terrance loves it and Ellen laughs at it
you know because it's kind of ridiculous
and and lost but you know just the
sacrifices you have to make I gotta go
congratulations on the movie thank you
hope it's a huge hit thank you